une campagne électorale ce sont des
promesses des débats des revirements
mais aussi des chiffres
l'élection du 1er octobre sera la 42e
élections générales depuis 1867 au
québec est la première à se tenir à date
fixe en tout 125 députés siègent à
l'assemblée nationale la dissolution
soixante huit députés libéraux étaient
présents à québec contre 28 péquiste 21
caquistes 3 solidaire et cinq
indépendants remporter une élection ça
coûte de l'argent il ya les déplacements
les publicités les affiches électorales
mais au québec les dépenses sont très
encadrés seul un électeur peut
contribuer à la campagne d'un candidat
ce qui exclut les entreprises et les
syndicats par exemple le montant maximal
d'une contribution est fixé à 200
dollars en tout plus de six millions
d'électeurs sont appelés aux urnes en
2014 plus de 70% d'entre eux ont exercé
leur droit de vote
il est aussi possible de voter par
anticipation une façon de faire qui
gagne en popularité à la dernière
élection
un électeur sur cinq a voté avant le
jour du scrutin
et vous si vous vous demander de quel
côté du paysage politique vous êtes
faites le test de la boussole électorale
de radio canada
cet outil est disponible sur notre site
internet à cette adresse boussole point
radio canada.ca